شعرت بأنها في أفضل حالاتها عندما كانت تتحرك
[تصفيق]
في مارس 2020 ، أصبحت
نيويكر مرغوبة فقط في 43 عامًا كانت نيتزا شابة
وبصحة جيدة ولم تكن قلقة للغاية
حتى إحدى الليالي في أبريل استيقظت
في منتصف الليل بسبب الإعجاب
صوت
قرع أو دق كان
صوت قلبي حرفيًا
وذهبت إلى غرفة الطوارئ ،
ما تكشفت بعد ذلك قصة
كوفيد طويل قصة تكررت الآن
ملايين المرات في الولايات المتحدة
، ملحمة من الأطباء يزورون جميعهم تقريبًا
مما أدى إلى نتائج اختبار عادية
على الرغم من شعورها بخلاف ذلك ،
لقد عانيت للتو من الكثير من الأعراض الغريبة والغريبة
للشهر التالي والتي
ساءت بشكل تدريجي ثم تصاعدت
إلى رعشات
تعتقد أننا نتعامل مع نوع جديد
من المرض هنا أعتقد ذلك.  الدكتور زين
تشن هو المدير الطبي لمركز جبل سيناء
لرعاية ما بعد الطمع ، وهو أول
مركز من هذا القبيل تم إنشاؤه في الدولة
، هل أنت قادر على التنبؤ
بمن هو الأكثر احتمالا لتطوير رغبة طويلة
هؤلاء المرضى المقدمين  إلى
المستشفيات التي تعاني من أشد الأعراض خطورة
أثناء المرض الأولي ، فإن خطر
تعرضهم لأعراض طويلة الأمد يكون
أعلى
ولكن هذا لا يعني أنك تعرف ما إذا
كنت تعاني من حمى صغيرة أو أعراض خفيفة
في المنزل ، فأنت محصن ضد مرض كوفيد.
الآثار الباقية شاسعة من
الدماغ إلى قلوبنا
، دراسة على مرضى من فرجينيا كانوا قد
اشتهوا في وقت مبكر من الوباء كانوا
أكثر عرضة بنسبة 60 في المائة لتطوير
أي مشاكل قلبية بما في ذلك
أمراض القلب والسكتة القلبية لمدة عام كامل
ولكن الفكرة أن  حتى لو لم
أصاب بالمرض لدرجة أنني قد أعاني من أعراض طويلة الأمد ،
لا أريد المبالغة في ذلك ، لكن
كم هو مخيف
أنه مخيف للغاية أعني أنه مثل
الصعود إلى طاولة القمار في فيغاس
والمخاطرة بخسارة كل شيء
و  هذا ما يجعل الأمر
محيرًا للغاية
، فليس من الواضح من الذي طور فيروس كورونا منذ فترة طويلة
من يتعافى أو لماذا يحدث في
المقام الأول.
بعد ثلاثة أشهر على الأقل من الإصابة ، أعتقد أن الشيء الذي
فاجأنا أكثر هو
مجرد تنفس المرض ، مثل سبب وجود العديد من
الأعراض المختلفة
حتى الآن هناك فقط نظريات بأن
جهاز المناعة مفرط النشاط لا يزال يحاول
محاربة الفيروس على الرغم من عدم وجوده.
مصاب بعد الآن أو ربما أجزاء من
الفيروس لا تزال مخبأة في أجسامنا أو
ببساطة حطام الفيروس الذي
يمكن أن يسبب أشياء مثل جلطات الدم التي
تخنق تدفق الدم إلى كل شيء
من أنفنا إلى أصابع قدمنا ​​، لقد عانيت من كل
هذه الأعراض الغريبة بما في ذلك
الأرجل المرتعشة و  لم تستطع ذراعي تحريك
ساقي ، لقد بدأت المشي بعصا ،
حيث قابلت العديد من أطباء الأعصاب
وأطباء القلب
عشرات الزيارات مع كل شخص يحاول
معالجة عضو معين من جسدها ،
ولم يحدث أي من ذلك فرقًا
حتى وصلت إلى جبل سيناء مكانًا
تقوله بدقة.  ركز عليها كمريض كامل
بدلاً من طردها من العمل ، يمكن لطبيبي في
الواقع إنهاء الجمل بالنسبة لي
حول كيفية
ظهور
الأعراض  لقد أصابتني
هنا حتى على الرغم من عدم وجود
إجابات سهلة ، ولا يزال فيروس كورونا الطويل
لغزًا بالنسبة لنتسا ، فقد وجدت بعض
الراحة من المنشطات ، وعلى مدار عام
من العلاج الطبيعي ، لا تزال تعاني من
ضباب في الدماغ في بعض الأحيان ولا
تزال حركتها محدودة لكنها عادت  للعمل
وعلى قدميها يمكنني ممارسة الرياضة مقارنة
بالعام الماضي ، أود أن أقول إنني أجري
ماراثون الآن
دكتور سانجاي جوبتا سي إن نيويورك